it's a concert film but it's also a
story at the same time
billy eilish is transforming into an
edgy disney princess to give fans a
cinematic concert experience i did that
disney plus unveiled the first official
trailer for the singer's upcoming
happier than ever a love letter to los
angeles which drops on september 3rd i
definitely have fantasies about l.a
a whole different world interwoven with
my world
the special will include animated
elements taking viewers on a dreamlike
journey through her hometown of los
angeles and its most iconic backdrops it
will also offer an intimate performance
of every song in billy's new album
happier than ever for the first and only
time and get this she will rock the
stage at the legendary hollywood bowl
this kind of beautiful version of old
hollywood
and the hollywood bowl it's very
timeless
[Music]
this is my entire album from front to
back in order the seven-time grammy
award winner will also feature her
brother phineas the los angeles
children's chorus and philharmonic and
many more this is a dream come true
the singer first announced the once in a
lifetime experience in july writing on
instagram this was the most surreal
shoot ever and i cannot wait for you to
experience this film we all have these
idealized
versions of ourselves in our head since
its debut in july her new album has
spent three consecutive weeks at number
one on the billboard 100.
it's also been a busy year for billy who
scored two grammys in march including
record of the year something she may be
used to as the 19 year old singer made
history as the youngest artist to
receive major grammy wins and
nominations last year billy crazy night
this turned into your night i guess
what does this mean to you i'm dying man
i don't know it's crazy
but it's billy's latest look that has
fans happier than ever the bad guy
singer rocked her fresh hairstyle on
social media a shaggy bob billy's inspo
her mom the star shared throwback snaps
of her mother maggie with a similar do
writing like my mama are people coming
up to you asking about your style is it
weird that people are so
intrigued and interested it's it's
really
sick it's kind of exactly what i'd want
people to care about you know yeah like
i don't know the things that the people
sort of know me for are all the things i
want to be known for if that makes sense
because style has always been something
i care about you know visuals and videos
and
you know designs and stuff is also
something and you know those are the
things people sort of ask me about or
confidently about which i think is i'm
really grateful for that